hi thanks for coming and thank you for
the lucky talk I'll continue my talk
from yesterday so we're trying to show
an exponential separation of information
and communication and this was our main
result we show separation between
communication and information and
basically for every parameter k will see
a function and a distribution such that
the information cost of the function is
very low it's only okay but the
communication is at least exponential
it's at least two to the K and this will
mean that interactive protocols cannot
always be compressed to their
information content so what I want to do
in this talk I want to tell you a little
bit more about this separation about the
example that's separate information and
communication so tomorrow it yesterday I
sketched a search problem and a
simplified distribution today I want to
show you the actual construction the
actual function so it will be a proper
boolean function and the actual
distribution it's slightly more
complicated than what we had before and
I want to show you the upper bound that
we didn't get to show you yesterday so
we'll see some more details today
basically and hopefully get a flavor of
this result so the first few slides are
going to be very close to what we had
yesterday with one difference let me
just remind you what we're doing or how
we construct this example we're gonna
have an underlying tree it's complete
binary tree we're grouping every 100k
layers together in co it a multi-layer
and this tree is very very deep it it
has 2 to the 4 to the K multi layers and
we had input so Alice got some X and Bob
got some Y such that X contains one bit
for every vertex in the tree and why
contains a possibly different bit for
every vertex in the tree so this is a
vertex
Alice get some bet Bob gets another bet
and we remarked that the input sizes is
huge here let me remind you the
definition of typical vertices so we
assume that Alice owns the odd layers
and Bob owns the even layers and then
that the player who owns a vertex really
tells us what is the right way to go if
you reach this vertex so if Alice owns
the verdicts and herb it is zero it
means that they're suppose the players
supposed to go left and if she has a one
they're supposed to go right and then
the important definition was of a
typical node where we said that a node
is typical so you need to fix I x and y
with respect to the multi-layer and two
inputs so it's typical if it's in a
multi-layer that is after multi-layer I
so let's take this guy suppose that it's
just after multi-layer I but it can be
anywhere in here and that the sub path
leading to it ah in multi-layer I he has
at least eighty percent correct children
so we only look at this part of the past
and we check that eighty percent of the
time we went to the right direction with
respect to x and y so x and y tell us
what is the right direction and I'm
asking you to go at least eighty percent
of the time to the right direction with
respect to the inputs so this was the
definition and we also remarked that
typical vertices are arranged in sub
trees so if this guy is typical every
node in its subtree is also typical and
those are the typical lives so this we
had from yesterday yesterday I defined a
simplified distribution you I want to
give you the D proper distribution that
we're using in a paper so as we said
before we have two types of vertices the
first type is called no noisy and it
means that x and y are choosing at
random and are choosing to be the same
Oh for non oi 0 dresses we give Alice
and Bob the same bit it's just a random
bit but it's the same bit and for noisy
vertices x and y are the bits given to
Alice or Bob are selected independently
at random ok so no noise means that they
have the same vets noise means that the
bits are independent they have no idea
what the other guy got and this is the
actual distribution it's kind of similar
to what we had before with a twist ok so
as we done yesterday you randomly select
a multi-layer suppose you selected this
multi layer and then all the vertices
before multi-layer I all the guys in
here I said to be no noisy ok so Alice
and Bob will get the same bits for every
vertex in here multi-layer I is noisy so
every vertex a multi-layer I said to be
noisy all the guys in here all the
vertices in here are selected the bits
for them are selected independently for
Alice and Bob and now this is the twist
this is the new thing for layers after
multi-layer multi-layer I will have what
we call bursting noise looks like that
ok so before what we had yesterday is
everything in here was white we was no
noisy now we will have some of the
vertices will be noisy and some of the
vertices will be no noisy and actually
the non typical vertices will be noisy
so if this guy is not typical so this
part of the path does not contain eighty
percent correct children this guy is not
typical all the subtree rooted that this
vertex is going to be noisy but if this
guy is typical then everything beneath
it it's subtree is going to be no noisy
so this is a slightly more complicated
definition the complication is only year
so this was not noisy it's still no
noisy this is no easy as it was before
and before I define this to be no noisy
now part of it is noisy and parties no
noisy and
we think that you can work with
everything in here being no noisy but we
don't know how to show that and it's
very crucial for the actual analysis to
have noise even on the bottom and I'll
say a little bit more about that but
this is also the reason we call it the
bursting noise because like if this
noise is if this vertex is nothing the
nose kind of burst out of it this is the
reason for the name again we don't know
if it's just technical or it's really
needed we think its technical but it's
really the proof really relies on this
kind of noise but this is the definition
so there is once passion layer this
layer which is noisy everything before
is no noisy and on the bottom we have
this weird tapestry with Nonie noisier
no noisy which we carefully select and
I'll remark about that later questions
about the the new actual distribution
okay so yesterday I told you that the
goal of the players this was the search
problem right the goal was to find an
output the same typical leaf so give me
anything in here like any typical if is
ok as long as you give me the same
typical if so again we're just asking
you to find some leaf such that this
part of the path leading to it contains
eighty percent correct children and this
was a search problem because there are
many possible outputs for every pair of
inputs so I want to convert it to a
function but before let me just repeat
why we think you should maybe believe me
that the communication should be high so
I argued that guessing a random leaf is
not a good idea because there is a very
small probability of it being actually
typical because the random leaf will
have eight fifty percent of the path
correct and we asked for eighty percent
and we also said that the kind of the
key to solving is knowing multi-layer I
if the player is no move
I they can just follow the path from say
this point casino multi-layer I and they
can just communicate the information on
multi-layer I the thing is the tree is
so deep that they can't find multi-layer
I efficiently so they somehow need to
give information on all the multi layers
and this is very wasteful so of course
the analysis is is not that simple and
maybe now I should room an open makrand
have a simplified proof of this of this
lower bound and they're going to present
it tomorrow at 5pm if you want to listen
so definitely what they do is is shorter
than what we do and is simplified so I
think it's worth the effort okay so i
won't talk about the digest day they'll
give the details for that but this is
kind of a sanity check and you can see
that those claims they hold even without
the bursting noise I mean I told you
about that yesterday why do I put this
bursting noise in why do I need like
maybe it's enough for this multi-layer
to be noisy and the reason is kind of an
intuitive on intuitive level the
bursting noise makes the game harder for
the players they have less in common if
everything in here is no noisy it's all
white then they have more in common
maybe they can somehow use that to solve
the game by adding noise here I make the
game harder for them and therefore
potentially easier for me to show lower
bounds on the game so really the bracing
noise is only used in the lower bound
proof and this will be so this kind of
noise also existing in mulund and an
oops proof so we don't know how to get
rid of it but it helps us for the lower
bond so now I want to convert to a
function so remember what the task that
before the search problem was just give
me any typical leaf but now I want a
proper search I want a proper boolean
function okay so the output size here
was huge
and it was a search problem now we want
a function with small output size okay
so here is how we do that what you do is
you update your distribution meal okay
so this was the distribution yo this is
the way we selected x and y now we do
something are slightly different we
first select x and y as before okay so
suppose we selected things according to
the skin now we do an additional step
you randomly select some bits be either
0 or 1 with probability half and half
and then for every leaf you add to yv to
Bob's input you all be to it okay / GF 2
okay mods too ok so again you construct
X or Y as before but now you have this
special bit be what you do is you you
give x2 Alice exactly as before but
before giving bit too before given Y to
be you add this be to every vb so this
leaf will get it used to have some value
right now we add be to it and we do that
for every leaf but just for Bob ok so
this is the construction you add b2y V
for every for every leaf V and the
function is if you give if we give the
players x and y we expect them to give
us be back and this is a well-defined
function ok so it's a function great
it's a boolean function clearly why
would it make any sense so ok first note
that for any typical leaf when you sum
up vb + y v XV sorry XV NY v you get
exactly be why is that because if the
leaf is typical right it's somewhere in
here it's not noisy see the white is no
noisy X was equal to Y to begin with so
to begin with X was equal to Y and then
we added to be to V
so too sorry thanks to why where'd it be
to why so now the Sun is be okay so
before they were equal and now we edit
this bit why so the sum is be so this
says that if you want to determine B it
suffices to find a typical leaf if you
solve the search problem then you can
easily solve the function right because
if i find it typical if I just some the
bits and I get an eye out to this be
it's very easy ok but not that if you
have a non-typical leaf then the sum is
going to be just random because for non
typical lives right this is an auntie
those are non typical lives you can see
that they're noisy which means that x
and y to begin with were just
independent and then we added some be to
why they're still just independent right
so the sum is going to be random if you
know a typical leaf then you can solve
and if you try to use a different lifts
that is not typical then it wouldn't
give you anything ok so of course it
doesn't mean that if you solve the
function you solve the game it just
means that it I mean just one direction
here is true if you solve the search
problem you solve the function but we
don't know that the other way also works
so this is the construction and this
gives a function and maybe like on some
intuitive level so I can't actually see
this clock from here 15 ok great so let
me maybe say it again how we were doing
this function thing ok so we have all
the like take this said to be the set of
Olives those are all the possible
outputs and there is for every action
why there is a set of outputs that is
correct those are the typical lives
okay so four of his x and y we have the
typical even this is the set of Olives
and what we do is is we want to map the
typical lifts to some be some vit b and
we want map all the other leaves to
random or arbitrary a bit and this is
exactly what we do so for typical leaves
we make them share be okay so x and y
are shares of this beef you excel them
together you get b and for all the other
leaves if you sort together you get
nothing it's just random so this is kind
of a more general statement right you
can always take the good set the correct
set and map it to some bit which is the
output of your boolean function and all
the rest you should make sure that they
give no information about the actual b
and this is basically what we do this is
a proper boolean function questions
about the function okay great okay so
now I want to show you the protocol with
low information costs so hopefully you
have some vague idea of why you should
expect that a communication is at least
2 to the K but now I want to claim that
the information is at most is exactly
okay and this is this direction is much
easier than the lower bound it's an
upper bound will will show that they
will see the protocol it's not
complicated the analysis is not very
simple but it's much simpler than the
lower bound proof okay so this is the
protocol there is a minor bug that will
fixed but it basically goes like that
you start from the root and then on
every vertex V you encounter the player
who owns V sends his bit with
probability ninety percent and send the
negation of his bit with probability ten
percent okay so what and okay so then
they select they have a new vertex and
then they
we move to the child indicated by this
bit okay so everyone like okay let's see
the example so Alison's the roots right
if she had zero for the root then she
needs to send 0 with probability ninety
percent and she needs to send 1 with
probability ten percent so in this
example she sent 20 and they get to this
red vertex and now Bob on this red
vertex if we have the one for this
vertex then they should go right with
probability in ninety percent it should
send 1 with probability ninety percent
and it should send 0 with probability
ten percent so in this example he sent a
zero so they go here and so on let's
define a path just it's a very easy
protocol says state your actual bit with
probability ninety percent negate your
bit with probability ten percent and the
players move to the earth child that was
indicated and then if eventually you
reach some leaf and what the players do
is they output the sum of the bits that
they have for their slaves so if they
got here Alice tells Bob what xvii is he
kicks or it with yv and this is the
output and ok so hopefully this is the
bit be that we're looking for and the
easy part is showing correctness it's
easy to show that this protocol solves
the function computes the function with
high probability and the reason is that
by Chernoff bound we're very likely to
reach a typical leaf the reason is that
we're going ninety percent to the right
direction so with very high probability
on this part of the path will go at
least eighty percent to the right
direction okay so on average in
expectation we're going ninety percent
to the right direction and we only need
to go at least eighty percent this will
happen with high probability so with
high probability were really solving
this game this clear why it's solving
the the function
good um so the question is now okay so
it does solve it but what why would I
claim that the information is low
clearly the communication is horrible
the communication is the depth of the
tree which is double exponential in K so
we know we can get exponential in k
right so the depth that the
communication is is horrible but I'm
claiming that the information is really
small okay so this is what I want to
claim next but maybe before I want to
tell you why we go ninety percent of the
right direction and not a hundred
percent to the right direction it seems
that this will be the same right or
maybe better they'll go exactly to the
right place and it turns out that this
90 is very important it's not important
that it's a 90 it's important that it's
between 80 and 100 and it's important
that it's not exactly 100 and the reason
is the following if the players always
send their troop it then this will
reveal I so it will reveal the noisy
multi-layer and the reason is that ok
suppose that they agree to always say
the right bit then the first time that
Bob disagrees with Alice what she sends
is different more than what he had then
he knows that they probably reach
multi-layer I okay because if they
didn't reach multi-layer I they're
supposed to agree on the bits so the
first time they disagree he knows that
they got 22 multi-layer I and this is a
problem because then the information
costs will be at least the length the
representation of I the size of Phi
which is Loxy bits cuz I is a number
between 1 and the depth of the tree and
this is too much Loxy is too much
because we took three to be double
exponential so lock see it's still
exponential this is not good enough
because in this case the information
costs will be too high it will be
exponential inking and somehow this ten
percent error going to the wrong
action with probability ten percent will
hide the eye and like intuitively the
reason is that now if Bob disagrees with
Alice he believes that with hyper-v t
this is just due to the ten percent she
just negated a bit that's the reason we
disagree it makes less sense for him to
assume that this is because they reach
multi-layer I I mean what's the
probability that it we reach multi-layer
I one over C there is a probability of
ten percent that she just negated a bit
and that's the reason we disagree so
somehow the ten percent hides I and it
keeps the information go fraction of
disagreements and it's going to suggest
that it's noisy but i guess the issue is
there's so many layers that exactly yeah
so what Andy's indicating is is right so
the first time they disagree okay I told
you a bob will believe that this is due
to their ten percent air and okay but
then it's gonna happen if when they
actually reach multi-layer I it's going
to happen like 100 k times in a row like
step after step they'll disagree a lot
and this is maybe you know this may
reveal multi-layer I but the thing is
that it as you said the trees so deep
that this even this is not a cause for
an alarm right because with some good
probability I mean the probability of
seeing 100 k times disagreeing 100 k x
is 1 it's a tenth to the 100k something
like that right if we didn't get to
multi-layer I just by chance 100 k times
we were doing the ten percent thing this
is only exponential in k the number of
layers we have is double exponential
it's something like that so this event
will happen many many times to give some
information about multi-layer I but very
small amount of information only K bits
okay so even disagreeing 100 k times is
not that weird
good any more questions what the
argument except now would only work
better so now I forget why why can't it
be under local the depth of the noise
will today the probability of guessing
that the political note
okay so the probability is exponentially
smiling whatever you right here other
questions oh okay good question no the
answer is no okay okay so let me just
give you some intuition on why you
should believe that the information cost
is Oh FK so why it would it be low ok so
I'm claiming that when we do our
protocol when we run our protocol there
are two types of vertices that we
encounter non-typical Curtis isn't
typical and no noisy vertices and noisy
vertices for no noisy vertices a player
learns very little information about the
input of the other player because he
kind of already knew the input of the
other player ok so here for example
Alison Bob got the same bit so when
Alice tells Bob her bit he's not that
surprised it doesn't learn a lot from
that because he kind of already knew
that of course he wasn't true that he
actually knows that but he was pretty
convinced like he had a zero she said a
zero ok it makes sense so it doesn't
reveal a lot of information and it
actually really little information so
all the vertices that are not noisy all
the things in here and all the things in
here will be very very little
information we actually reveal
information or noisy vertices on my
favorite assess the inputs were
independent when Alice tells Bob her bit
it can give him one bit of information
so for every noisy verdicts the other
player may learn one bit of information
and then we are claiming that with high
probability a typical leaf is reached
this is what we said before we're
solving the game without the function
with high probability and therefore
we're very likely to only reach 100 k on
noisy vertices only the vertices in
multi-layer I are going to be noisy so
we're paying 100 k information for this
ok because the
100 K vertices times one bit of
information for each and I'm clearing
that all the rest of the vertices the
guys in here and they got all the guys
that are in white will give us very very
small amount of information and
therefore you should expect that their
information is okay and now that here we
had to be very careful with designing
the bursting noise we want to put noise
over the all thing here but we can't we
must make this we must allow for the
space to to patent on to only encounter
white vertices with high probability so
if everything here was noisy then this
path willink won't encounter too many
noisy vertices and then the information
will go up so we must make sure that
everything in here is no noisy okay so
if the path needs to go through here
this needs to be no noisy to not incur
high information costs okay and so the
birthing know is for the lower bond but
we need to make sure that the upper
bound still works and this is the reason
we have the step astray of noises on the
bottom so one last slide I want to tell
you what the bug is so I said there is a
little bug with the protocol and the bug
is the following with some small
probability we do reach a non-typical if
so it may happen that the path will go
through here it will happen with
exponentially small probability but this
is still a problem because if it happens
this is very very deep and it's all
noisy so in this case we may give an
additional 2 to the 4 to the K bits of
information which is too much because
you know this time this is double
exponential we can't afford this so this
is luckily easy to correct and the way
to correct it is that we have the
players a bore
when they reach when when they reach
this situation so if you reach the
birthing noise we ask the players to
abort and it turns out that they can
actually detect they can actually tell
whether they voted a bursting noise and
basically they can see that if they
reach the bursting noise then they're
going to disagree exponentially number
we say it again so to detect whether you
got to the bursting noise the players
will try to see whether in the last
exponentially many rounds they disagreed
at least eighty percent more than eighty
percent they agreed less than eighty
percent of the time okay so they have an
exponential counter something like 2 to
the K and they check whether in whether
they disagreed in the last 2 to the K
rounds with high probability this is the
case it's probably because they got to
the bursting nose and then they just
terminate and fail but this will only
happen with like small probability
something like 2 to the minus K and this
is part of the air so we can actually
take care of this annoying case and
thinking we're thank you to Andy for
pointing that out because in the
original version we had something more
complicated so they're both works thanks
okay so this is it i think yeah
questions
questions for the seeker okay that's
fine it was s if we made the randomness
that a player has no choices mm-hmm
randomness also part of their input haha
then like all these random choices that
I'm making because this car tomatoes so
you're reeling this oh yeah then you're
giving too much information because the
thing is we were not charging for
private randomness so when we disagree I
learned something about either your
input or your randomness which you call
your input now so the and this is
typically how it goes so usually the
private randomness helps us to reduce
the information kind of makes us allow
us to hide the actual information in
kind of random information that is not
part of what we charge for
okay do you think that a similar
counterexample would exist if you did
not allow five if I did I've been
charged for all everything I learned
about the other side whether it's a
spider venom is 40 years saying that
there is no private randomness and this
goes to scheisse stalker I know if he's
here oh yeah he's here cuz then I'd be
really mad because I came to your talk
so yeah shy shy talks about the case
where there is no private randomness and
this is exactly what you're saying that
this is part of the input and then we
have very good compressions and we you
couldn't get something like ours and I
think shy mentioned it am I saying that
correctly okay